I met him perhaps around 1967 and he was
doing this very very deep work his his
books were coming out at that time and
having a profound effect especially on
the nuns I was teaching at a Catholic
College Marymount College in Tarrytown
and the nuns were finding all manner of
personal epiphanies in the readings the
reading of Europe of your grandpa and so
I was a very young teacher then and they
said let's get Viktor Frankl here and
we've got enough money together which in
those days wasn't very much I mean
there's a lot left at that time and we
brought him in and I remember him as
being a rather small man quite short and
I'm quite tall I'm 5 11 so hear me and
he looked at us with great solemnity and
I was wondering why is he looking so
solemnly he had all these little
Catholic girls but he it was as if he
was seeing something that we teachers
often did not see we talked about the
state of the world as I recall and his
sensibilities about where we were and
what was happening in the post-war years
and also the rising of the depths of the
psyche and how
how the enormous changes that one saw in
the 20th century were acting activating
very very deep changes in the psyche but
that the level of suffering that had
ensued at least in the first half of the
20th century mr. sixty-seven would
result in a kind of repression I've
never thought of this before
repression of the shadow and we would
not be dealing with the shadow that was
the nature of our conversation and it's
funny just in talking to you his
grandson is this memory that I have
completely forgotten about has come up
yeah and of course that subsequently is
what happened now remember this is 1967
and this is also be the birth of the big
60s movement the music is changing the
energy is changing we're all having a
whole lot of fun and I realized now in
terms of his perspective because we
didn't see those big shadows I mean with
who was it I guess it was Bob Dylan was
singing you know something is happening
and you don't know what it is do you mr.
Jones and it was as if mr. so that mr.
Victor Frankl was mr. knew and was
informing all the Miss Jones's you know
about what was really about to emerge
that was way beyond what but it wasn't
going to happen for another about 6-7
years after this great explosion and
expressiveness had taken its form
between the fall of the Berlin Wall in
1989 the end of the Cold War
essentially and the fall of the twin
towers in 2001 we had a great
parentheses of time in the United States
and in some other countries as well in
which to do our deep work on our own
shadows because America had a ton of
shadow you know from our treatment of
indigenous people black people our home
people but we did to the lands and we
had projected that shadow onto very
projectable European tyrants Hitler
etcetera and then at the end of World
War two we thought of ourselves as good
as the best is the kindest the nicest
you know the martial plans etc and we
reprojected the entire shadow under the
Soviet Union you know and as I say
between that fall of the Berlin Wall in
the fall of the 2001 those two towers
those two great huge walls this
parenthesis of time when we could have
done something with this shadow you know
it really it had a kind of national
reflection but we didn't it became the
time of the core policies you know
cultures of greed and we did not
so naturally we got the incarnation of
that same shadow in the neo-fascist form
of the of the last administration
and he was predictive of that as I
recall in our conversation what would
happen that's what I remember
you
you